beware of False Prophets
Who come to you in Sheep's Clothing
For inwardly they are Ravening Wolves
Jesus is the Shepherd who protects you from those wolves
and I, am his dog
the sheepdog that get the lambs back on track when they stray off the path
And some of you have strayed, haven't you?
Mama? Are you evil?
Reverend says he's here to take you back where he came from
I know you're there. And I know you can hear me. You may have no tongue but there is nothing wrong with your ears
Do you know, why I'm here?
I'm here to punish you
Why do you let him do this?
It's a sin
I love him!
You do not. It is lust.
He ain't never gonna stop, is he?
I've seen your mother she's the kind of person that turns the other cheek, be like her.
Never leave your loved ones alone, you should know that by now